[Musique]
combien de poussins mâles sont tués à la
naissance chaque année dans le monde
6,5 milliards dans l'industrie des
poules pondeuses les mâles sont jugées
inutiles parce qu'il ne pompe pas deux
de plus ils n'agressent pas suffisamment
pour produire assez de cher selon les
standards du marché c'est que de nos
jours des rats spécifiques sont élevées
pour produire soit des oeufs ou de la
viande résultat les travailleurs des
couvoirs l'endroit chargé de l'éclosion
des oeufs identifie le sexe du poussin à
la naissance si c'est une femelle elle
est expédiée vers les élevages de poules
pondeuses si c'est un mâle on le tue
immédiatement il est asphyxié au dioxyde
de carbone ou broyées vivante une
solution est toutefois à portée de main
en france et en allemagne où cette
pratique vient d'être interdite les deux
pays testent une technologie qui permet
de déterminer le sexe dans l'embryon
avant l'éclosion question d'empêcher les
mâles de naître il faudra attendre de
voir si la pratique qui est actuellement
utilisé de façon expérimentale pourra
être reprise par la grande industrie
oui